keys to getting suggestive suggested is
the number one way to grow your channel
in thought leadership suggests this is
where you want to go because just
setting the framework because you want
your content to live forever search is
only 30 of entire YouTube and browse is
way too Hit or Miss way too trendy to be
able to win consistently on so inside of
flat leadership suggests it is where you
want to play your content lives forever
but before that happens you have to rank
against yourself so Step One is how do I
get suggested against myself and this is
where at the beginning stages of a
channel can feel slow growth because
you're not getting picked up against big
channels ultimately your big growth
comes from being suggested against big
channels against huge videos you want to
be suggested against my videos against
Tony Robbins videos against Brandon
Richard videos or inside your Niche
that's where your big growth comes but
that doesn't happen until you get
suggested against your own videos first
and just think about in YouTube's
perspective why would they show you
against some big video If you're not
even showing up against yourself if
you're not even for your own audience
converting people over to want to watch
they're not going to show you against
the big videos what ends up happening is
you see the slow go slow go slow growth
and then once suggests it becomes your
number one traffic Source oftentimes you
see an explosion of growth for the
channels because it means you're
suggested against your own then you get
suggesting sellers so let's show how to
do it and this for this video I'm going
to uh break down my own channel my top
10 Channel
and kind of take you guys a little
behind the scenes of what we're doing
and the advice I would give myself so
that I can go give my team as well to go
execute so if I look at the breakdown
for my top 10 Channel suggested
is number one so 22 uh Channel pages is
number two because we promoted off my
main page then browse and search
everything else right so the search is
nine percent
it's not huge and and it shouldn't be
huge and if your goal is to get people
to subscribe to your channel right if
you have some utility Channel where you
don't care about subscriptions then
search can be great but if we care about
people coming back and watching content
consistently suggestions where you need
to be so this is where we get massive
growth so how do you show up against
your own videos how do you get suggested
against your own channel
here's what you need to do a couple
things one consistent design
so if you look at my channel you look at
my videos as always at consistent design
you know what an Evan Chronicle
thumbnail looks like
right and on this channel
we use white uh whatever blue we want to
call that and then still the logo
right and so whether these are the new
videos that just came out this is these
are the videos that are the most popular
so some of these are a year ago
whether it's you know something that
came out yesterday or something came out
a year ago it's still the same kind of
style the only one that's different is
this one which isn't that different this
is where we were testing having the text
all being in a block
so it's just one big Square where
everything else we found this actually
performs better where it's not all
chunked right so you have different
lengths of the lines it's easier to read
um but besides that that's a pretty
minor change I look at that it's like oh
that one's really different but for most
people looking at it they're like okay
this is this is a diamond comical
thumbnail so I need to know what does
your thumbnail style look like because
to show up suggested against our own and
I know we've talked about this in the
past when they've clicked on if I click
on this Brandon Richard video here and I
like it it's like oh I like this channel
I'm going to look down the side and see
what else is there and if I can't
recognize your thumbnail because it's a
totally different style then I'm not
going to click on it so you're losing
views on your own videos
so it doesn't have to be exactly the
same that is a mistake so not exactly
the same not the exact same LinkedIn
profile picture it's what a lot of
people will do exact same picture they
have one good picture of them
and then that's the picture on every
single thumbnail don't do that right uh
you'll see none of these are actually
the fancy pictures they're screenshots
from within the video every single one
of these is a screenshot within the
video
uh similar text similar font similar
logo placement
it's okay to test in The Tweak in the
play but then the best thing you can do
is go back on your older videos when you
found the winning design and go test
those and improve them so that if I if
you go look at this channel
content as far as a year ago is all
going to be similar
so it encourages people to want to click
if they like it they want to click
second end card strategy I've tweaked
this up in the past when did we do this
three months ago two months ago
uh one big end card at the end linking
to the most relevant video not a
playlist
so if you look at my stuff six months
ago you would have seen an end card with
playlist playlist
uh subscribe and a link to my website to
get a lead magnet
and we looked at all the numbers uh and
this is actually outperforming all of
those combined
so this one end card at the end click
into a single video is outperforming the
four elements I used to have combined
so this is now what I'm doing on all my
channels is what I'm telling all the big
guys to do as well
at the end of every video you have 20
seconds to put with on the end card you
you point to the video so first you have
to pick the video right so this is a
video on Kevin O'Leary we're linking to
another Kevin O'Leary video the most
relevant related video to the one that
you just made that's already on your
Channel
and you could pitch it for 20 seconds or
you could talk about it for 10 seconds
have highlights from that video for 10
seconds you look to it you point to it
even at the end now I'm saying and I'll
see you there like that's at the end
both fingers the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
go watch that video Yeah Mark's got it
um there's arrows that fly in you know
big video right here in the middle hand
selected that that we think is going to
be the best one for them not YouTube's
most relevant uh or best reviewer not
YouTube's most recent you pick it uh and
again what we're doing is we're training
people that once they watch one video
they're watching another they're
watching another they're watching
another YouTube's gonna recommend your
videos a lot more to people so this has
had a uh a big impact on getting more
sessions more views in on the session
which then leads to more suggested views
as well
and then playlist in the newsletter if
any of you guys have newsletters
even if it's 500 people or you're
sharing to social media you have to put
the playlist in the newsletter so I've
talked about this before I can dive in
again if you guys want of how to do this
but basically if I look at this video
here so this is I don't think I've
shared this before where I share with
the news this is the newsletter
Jew is saying this is a must I'll cast
it's a huge deal so this is the actual
newsletter it's super short there's
there's basically nothing here right
this is the video that I'm trying to
promote and it's it's a picture Jamie uh
this is the video you know why did why
did Jamie get fired for talking too much
how did she how did she I even made a
typo how did she got from witness to
billionaire
find out my recent video on her right
uh this is a link this is a link this is
a link and the picture bounds a link so
there's four different links to the
video in here I experienced with a whole
bunch of different versions of this
where I'd have a lot more details I'd
show what the rules are I'd share the
highlights from it give a lot more
explanation it didn't lead to as many
clicks this leads to the most number of
clicks so super basic simple easy for
people to land on the video
Drew says I 3x the channel Revenue with
this one strategy
it's a big deal so then when they click
on the video they get to the video but
the key to that strategy is it shows
in the side my playlist so there's 445
videos here on this channel that are
public
so after this one they'll watch another
one and another one another one if they
if they leave it open some people may
close it that's fine but it auto leads
them to watch the next video on the
channel
and you can do a custom playlist if you
want most people find that too much work
I just do the uploads playlist and if
you guys need help and how to actually
find that link
I can uh we can do that at the end as
well during q a time but it's a big deal
so this is a little hard to see if I
zoom in on it you can see that there's
there's the video link and then at the
end it says and list equals so this adds
that playlist at the end so you still
get the same video The Experience from
the user is the same they're watching
the video I click for a video I get the
video but what happens after the video
ends is gonna send me down this Rabbit
Hole of all my other videos
uh almost nobody's doing it and if you
have a newsletter list or you're sharing
a social again if you're sharing a one
person doesn't make a difference but if
you're sharing to a group of people
that has the potential for lots of
people to click on it that can make a
big impact for you playlists can be uh
scary for people
playlist can be scary they don't want to
stand up and commit to watching 40
minutes or or whatever playlists can be
scary so it's one video and when I click
it again I get to the video so from a
user experience perspective I'm actually
still just getting that one video it's
just what happens at the end
what happens at the end is they'll go to
the next video automatically instead of
just a video ending
and what some people will do is they
will just have it open
in a tab they'll mute the video and have
it open in a tab
and then it just runs and they forgot
that they had this open in the tab
and eight hours later your videos are
still playing that counts for a lot of
watch time and then you get a lot more
suggested
how to win The Click it's great to show
up and suggested one of the things that
YouTube really cares about is are people
then clicking right are they clicking on
your video when they see yours down the
side or on the home page are they
actually clicking on it or not it could
have the best information possible but
one of the biggest things that I end up
doing with
um with some of the biggest channels as
well as my own is continue to tweak and
test to improve the click-through rate
on those videos because you could be
showing up but if nobody's clicking on
it YouTube's gonna stop showing you
right so win the click so my favorite
tool right now is tubebuddy to do this
um we've done a ton of different split
tests on tubebuddy you can you can test
the title you can also test the
thumbnail
if you are here on as a part of
somebody's team which I know some of you
are uh this is huge because to get
that person to then make new videos is
really complicated to go back and update
and tweak and test an old video is super
easy
and if you are here representing
yourself great same thing you know how
long and how much effort it takes to
make a new video versus hey if we just
throw a thumbnail tweak or title change
on this and it doubles the views of the
video that's a pretty good thing to do
right so it's a good investment of time
so tubebuddy is the only
um tool right now that that exists that
I would recommend I help them build the
a b testing
um I'm not a investor or owner of the
company just um I needed the tool for
myself
and we use it so if you're looking at
you know the tools
most of what the tools do I'm not a huge
fan of tubebuddy is actually great for
automation
so if you want to update the cards on
all your videos tubebuddy can help you
do it you want to update you want to put
a line at the top of your description to
say new book out or you know Jeff
Walker's doing his new launch so Casey
can update the description and say join
product launch formula today right
special offer for the next three days
right
you could update the first sign in the
description across all your videos
automatically
with a tool like tubebuddy uh to do it
manually it just you would just never do
it it's just insane to go back on all
the content now if you have 40 videos
okay it's not the end of the world if
you have 400 or my case you know 12 000
or whatever at right now it's just it's
just not possible it's just not a good
use of time so automation is what I
really love tubebuddy for and then the
split testing and vid IQ I love that in
the search results you can see how many
subscribers each channel has everything
else I'm not a fan of so helping you
pick keywords for your videos is all
junk
um
tags is completely useless a lot of
these tools have built their brand off
of tags like tags is zero YouTube's come
out and said tags count for nothing so
don't worry about the tags that you're
stuffing into the video and trying to
get the right you know there is no best
practice anymore it doesn't matter
um so that's where the tools I think let
you down but
used properly it can really help you uh
grow your channel so tubebuddy my
favorite tool is the split testing
tubebuddy it costs 49 bucks a month at
the highest level to do split testing is
49 a month so it's not it's not going to
break the bank it's not like some crazy
Enterprise tool that's twenty thousand
dollars a year to be able to get in on
and one of the things you can do with
the split testing is say okay I'm going
to test one video against another one
title against another so
you take a video that you want to
improve it's okay the original title so
here's one that I did
the original title was 10 ways to stop
making excuses and then the series name
and my team said okay what if we try the
10 morning routines you need to start
using right now
it's like okay I don't know I like both
of them
you know which one do you guys like
better but you can pop it in the chat A
or B which one you think is going to do
better
Terry says b
Casey says b Dan says a Peter says a
Anna says b Drew says hands down B Isaac
says b right so but here's the thing
like we have a mix of opinions I like
both of them
you know I like both of them Greg says B
I like I like both of them I picked the
first one my team picked the second one
you know but the thing is it's this is
where you can really get slowed down on
your YouTube creation because you don't
know what the right answer is and if you
have a team you could have different
opinions and say well I like this and I
like this and like okay what what do we
actually do well you do both and then
you let the data play out it's like data
driven decisions to help you grow your
channel so I ran this as an experiment
and the answer was B
so I was wrong
great hey but I'm win right and so the
way that tubebuddy basically works is
one day it had it's a b but on the same
video so one day it has title A the next
day it updates to title B the third day
back to title A the fourth day back to
title B and I'll just keep swapping
until you get enough data to say that it
does better so this is the same video I
didn't change this video right it's the
exact same video all I did was update
the title and we got a 73 Improvement in
the number of people clicking through on
the video
it's a pretty big deal
right we spend so much time making that
video how long did you spend thinking
about the title probably not that much
and then once it's up most people focus
on the next video that they're going to
record and create where often the the
biggest room for leverage is in your
catalog
to redo all those videos and constantly
test so great this one won we've
probably tested this another 20 times
okay it won perfect next what's another
title task we can do okay it lost
perfect next what's another test that we
can do so you're always testing and
trying to get the best ones to win and
so this is It's not that complicated a
tool to use
um and again for whatever reason we and
not just you guys like everybody focuses
on the next release where if you look at
where your views are coming from on your
channel it's likely from the library you
have some video that's three years old
that's still your number one video
and that's the beauty of YouTube your
contentless forever so hey how can we
make that three-year-old video pop even
harder by tweaking the thumbnail and
title so right now we're just focus on
titles so that one little change now 73
more people coming on the channel and
what YouTube does is if they see that
people are clicking through on your
videos more they're gonna start
recommending it even more
so now you're going to start showing up
even more
because we picked a better title now
it's not so much off of like what
keywords am I going to rank in search
for because again searches in the game
you know if we can get 73 more views on
a video you don't really care where it's
coming from it's coming from search
coming from suggested coming from browse
as long as they're real people watching
your video that could be subscribers
leads uh you know customers for your
business that's the main goal
so a couple other examples of things
that we've done you know Donald Glover
Charles Gambino top 10 rules of success
one of the big things we were doing was
leading with the name
versus leading with a message and when
we change it to Neville's never settle
for anything perfect another 26 increase
same video didn't make any tweaks or
changes just just tested the title
win
uh another one you know another top 10
was success versus the main theme you
know 41 Improvement
and so what we'll usually do is when we
have a new idea you know like like these
past two was lead with a message instead
of just leading with the you know top 10
rules leave with the message first we'll
test it on 10 videos
not every video will win but if we can
get 70 of the videos to win
then we go back and update everything
keep testing everything and it becomes
our new best practice going forward that
every new video we come up with is going
to follow this new best practice
there will be some that you just can't
beat
so don't stress out about being 10 out
of 10 every single one has to win
but if it's 70 plus each time then then
yeah that becomes our new best practice
another one you know Eric Thomas
motivation 2016 curious what you should
do from 22 to 30 you're gonna love this
advice 67 Improvement and sometimes it
looks
obvious afterwards like yeah yeah of
course that one would win
but when you're doing it you know no
just like when I that's why I showed you
hey a b and we had a split room yeah at
the beginning
um that's that's why because when you
think it might work you never know so
I'm not really
um
obsessed about being about me being
right I'm obsessed about getting it
right so if someone on the teams came
and said hey Evan I think this title
sucks how about we try this it's like
okay go for it like at this point you
don't even have to ask me as long as on
brand you know we're not we're not
anti-believed we're not you know doing
something violent or you know as long as
we're on brand but the team knows that
then just go do it because we're gonna
get results pretty quickly and and a lot
of channels just take way too long to
make decisions off of this and when
people ask me well which title do you
like better you get that a lot from
people with big channels some of my
friends like hey Evan which title do you
like better I don't know who cares what
I like better launch it and then a week
later try the second title and then see
which one does better data driven
decisions
I always recommend to not
do a test until at least one week after
the video is launched because in that
first week the data is kind of skewed
the first week is going to your
subscribers and notifications so don't
do a test on day two because the data is
going to be messed up or if you know
you're going to put it to your email
list or something right then don't do a
test while you're sending it out to your
email list because you're going to mess
up your data right look at how many
clicks we got on this video yeah but you
sent that to your newsletter right like
we're not you're not going to do that
every day what we care about is trying
to get it from suggested and browse and
people Rec being have the video be
recommended by YouTube
um so yeah so wait at least a week but
all your videos in your archive I'd go
back and start updating the only ones I
wouldn't is if it's super short it's
like a two minute video or something and
it's just a product promo that's going
to be really hard to get ranked so that
would be last on my list to go off and
do
but I've got
uh three and a half people
on my team
who are this is their job updating
titles and thumbnails across 10 000 Plus
videos
I say half because the half person
they're doing something else halftime
that I hired half a person
um now we talk about titles but even
more important than titles is thumbnail
people are visual the picture really
really makes a difference so if you want
to amp up your archive content
the picture becomes more important I'd
say 70 is from the thumbnail 30 is from
the actual title so if you're going to
be split testing split test thumbnail
first
and then you split test the the title
um for everybody we launch we have two
thumbnail versions ready to go we launch
it and then a week later we test the
other one and then we just have them
compete against each other and which
everyone wins that one wins and
sometimes it's this one that wins you
know 50 rules but more often than not
it's something like this where there's a
message I played this one song for 17
hours right it's like ooh what was that
song
that you play for 17 hours I want to
know what that is
right
um
but yeah variation one by 21 so again 21
more views on the video just by tweaking
the thumbnail
so the theme was how to build an
audience when most of your keywords have
heavy competition I love the game with
you guys
um and help you come up with the next
videos to make because I think a lot of
people struggle with what do I make next
and I'm making videos and nobody's seen
them and I don't know what topics to
work on
um I actually use Zen in the
presentation uh in Vegas uh in front of
everybody and I'll show you quickly what
I did and then hopefully we can workshop
with you guys too so if you think about
what are some of the videos that you
want to make
uh so for Zane what did I use Zane do
you remember what was what I put in how
to have confidence yes this is one of
the techniques that I often teach and
we've we've gone through it before but
I'd like to to customize it and get some
examples from you guys to make it
um more personal so
you know Zane's a confidence coach so
he's going to come here and look at how
to have confidence like that's maybe a
video title that he would come up with
and so
we use a video IQ plugin we've mentioned
this but it allows you to see how many
subscribers each channel has and so this
one you know eight million views that's
cool but it has 16 million subscribers
on the channel so it's an
underperforming video uh so we looked at
this one
you know how to be confident in any
situation
and I think Charlie just he's much he's
split testing this video because
yesterday was something else saying
wasn't this like how to radiant
confidence
so he Charlie looks like he's split
testing this video but it's got 13
million views and 5 million subscribers
so this this is one of the most popular
videos on his channel it's helping him
grow the channel and anytime we have a
higher sub count
um compared to the Views most most
videos were on the perform their sub
count so most videos we'll get if he's
got five million Subs we'll get less
than 5 million views whenever one does
really well that means it's a really
good video so we want to be taking on
this video so then I asked Stan in the
office hey Zane can you make this video
how to be confident anything he's like
yes perfect go make that video and and
what what we'll often find is the title
that we we think of is not the title
that we end up going with
right we started with how to have
confidence
and we end up with how to be confident
in any situation
right and then part two is this is to go
look at their Channel and then see what
their other videos are and if we sort by
their most popular ones
you can see you know they had to have
confidence one
what's here oh or did he do it twice no
it's here it's weird it's how to radiate
confidence under pressure
it's weird that it's showing up in
search is something different than on
his channel he must be doing a split
test
anyway this is the video and this is
number three video
so then you can look at what other
videos have gotten more than 5 million
views and there's not that many you know
he's got 5.3 million subs and this is
what 6 12 you know 15 16 videos have
more than 5.3 million views
out of all the videos that he's done on
his channel right like this will just
keep scrolling and these are still
decent videos right but they're not the
ones that are really growing his channel
so then you just look at all these and I
you know five five common habits that
make people instantly dislike you can
Zane do that video maybe maybe not you
know liking you is it tied to confidence
sure but it may not be in his wheelhouse
how to how to avoid embarrassing
yourself in an argument maybe you know
the Zayn talk about
arguments and negotiation embarrassment
you know it's it's on the verge
um but then something like this how to
turn awkwardness into confidence right
and then I asked and Zen can you make
that video it's like yes
like cool right and so you're just
basically looking for the videos that
are helping these videos are helping
grow
s on commands Channel
and even though it's you know it's
Charisma command not confidence on
command but there's a lot of confidence
related videos
so the one of the biggest shifts I was
trying to get people to make at the
conference was the game is not searched
the game is suggested because so many of
the experts teach search but most of the
views don't happen in search most of the
views happen What YouTube recommends you
so the goal is to rank after other
people's videos so the SEO game is how
do I show up after other people's videos
not how do I show up for that search
term and so
to the topic of how to build an audience
when your keywords of heavy competition
it's not so much about the keywords
having heavy competition it's any videos
that are doing really well awesome we
want to be trying to rank after them
so for for you guys are here are there
any topics themes that you want to
either pop in the chat or you know since
an intimate group you can unmike and
just we could Workshop it because I'd
love to be able to get
you leaving here with specific videos
you can go home and make
leadership skills
cool
so leadership skills is it is a really
broad topic right cool so that's a good
starting point so if we're here we're on
leadership skills
what do we got four tips improve
leadership skills with Brian Tracy
decent you know 649 versus 1.3 it's okay
10 leadership skills every leader should
have it's okay
1.6 versus 34. it's okay here's
something but Tony Robbins on the
psychology and skills of exceptional
leaders probably not one that you're
going to make unless you're going to
dissect Tony Robbins but not as good
this is actually this is actually rough
a lot of these are rough so far
here's one though how to be a great
leader the seven great leadership traits
1.3 million views off of 70 subscribers
or 70 000 subscribers
could you come up with seven great
leadership traits Terry
absolutely yeah so this is this is this
is a good one to make but overall this
is it also shows you how
how difficult it might be or how good a
topic is right so these people all have
a lot of subscribers actually this one
this one doesn't with the 1000 but a lot
of these videos they're getting a lot
fewer views and subscribers so it could
also lead us to think what else could we
call it instead of calling it leadership
skills what else could we call it
and by changing up one of those words we
might find a better topic so this is
this is this is a little bit below
average as a as a as a term but there
are still some gems in here you know
like this one how to be a great leader
seven great leadership trade this is the
best one on here
um
all of these are underperforming
unless it's specific right so set code
and even here garyvee talking leadership
skills 46 000 views but he's got 3
million subscribers
five crucial tips on leadership for
first-time managers
is that is that in the Wheelhouse Terry
or is that that's a good one I mean
because five crucial uh tips on
leadership for first-time managers I
mean the number one thing would be
developmental counseling
so I mean I have ideas in which I can
talk about on that
it's more does this so I mean cry five
if it was just five crucial leadership
five crucial tips on leadership cool but
for first time managers does that fit
into who you're trying to reach
it could I mean once again it's it's a
matter of of who I want to reach and and
if I'm wanting to reach first-time
managers yeah it'd be a good one
cool so this video really performed well
for him 18 000 Subs 238 000 views and
especially if you're a smaller Channel
looking at smaller channels right can
really help so
18 000 is not is not a it's not a tiny
Channel but it's not a giant Channel
either if we're looking at a Charisma
command it's got five million
subscribers
um so that's interesting body language
of leaders
is interesting I don't know if you go
that route or not Terry but I have I've
talked about things like for example how
the eyebrows is the most expressive body
part so I I do talk about some elements
of body language
so this is where it could get really
cool it's like hey you look at Vanessa
Fernandez this is the she's shown up a
couple times now right there's this
video but then there was this video
underneath
so this got 2.1 this got 360
000. I believe she was up higher
somewhere here
here 338 000. so when she's just talking
about leadership skills it's really
underperforming compared to talking
about the body language of leaders
yeah and this is what she's known for
but it's also you know it's what people
are searching for what they're
connecting with which is getting a lot
of traction on so could you provide your
perspective on the body language of
leaders and the goal becomes let's try
to show up after Vanessa van Edwards oh
yeah I probably have about seven to ten
things of body language I could talk
about for sure
cool and so that's that's the starting
point right so we've we've we've got
one video here second video here and
there was a third video
on this one right so these are so we've
got three video ideas that you can make
cool next is to look at all their
channels and see what other videos
they've got and if there's any fit
before even moving away so like already
leadership skills may not be the best
the best uh term because a lot of these
are underperforming so we can try on
another term that might give us a lot
more fruit but we've already got three
videos that we can use
right uh okay so next we go and look at
those channels you know
learning read the find was one what was
the other two this one burned burned
girop wow I probably butchered that name
uh and then Vanessa van Edwards okay and
then same thing
and the more
they're related to you the more options
it will be and there may not be anything
that you can pull from but you just sort
each one
and this gives us a starting point for
ideas six signs she wants you
laughs
okay Terry are we making all right that
was a good laugh though I like that one
we're probably not making that video but
you never know so 10 tricks to get her
to like you okay you know and a lot of
these look like book reviews uh so this
could be you know where Pablo comes in
you know with his book reviews and the
videos he likes he likes doing it
um but yeah so there may not be a lot
here that we can pull from but a lot of
these videos have done well
but could could Terry take that six
signs she wants you
and and as soon they come in it says
um women women loves a man who's a
leader and then
transition on his his three or four ways
to become the leader and what you you
follow me yeah so so there's two things
to that the first is
how ethical does like how how connected
does Terry feel to the message so it's
still got to be hard first and then you
wrap your brain around it right so if
it's just a strategy then if it's too
much of a stretch outside what you do
don't do it just because it's a good
topic okay otherwise you're going to end
up hating your channel and hating the
work that you're doing because you're
you're stretching like could you apply
leadership to anything yes can you play
confidence to anything yes of course
right but is that what you if Terry then
just goes and makes all of these kinds
of videos is he losing his soul
you know because it's just not fun to
make and the second part of that is are
you bringing in the right people so
ultimately what does Terry want to sell
you know if he if he wants to sell
leadership training and coaching
services for example
making a video six signs she wants you
is is probably targeting you know 13 14
16 18 22 year old guys and uh they're
probably not going to be anywhere close
to buying so unless he's playing a
really long game and this is like a
15-year play for Terry and just really
thinking ahead of the curve then it's
probably not the best fit and just move
on to other topics
welcome everybody uh so this month we're
doing a a topic breakdown and the theme
was importance of editing slash high
quality video and b-roll Etc that was uh
posted by Andrew so that's we're gonna
have a quick discussion on here and I
thought I'd pull up some channels and
talk about it too the key thing that we
want to think about here
all that matters in terms of editing and
b-roll is attention are you keeping
people's attention so the two things
that we need to focus on is can we get
people to click on our video
and clicking on the video is a function
of what are we calling it what's the
title what's a thumbnail so that we're
showing up and then people it's an
attractive thing that I want to click on
and go see
once they're on the video then it's
about retention are you keeping people
how much are people sticking around and
watching a video and this is where
editing slash b-roll slash whatever else
goes into production of the video
matters what I found over and over and
over again is inside education
the b-roll especially if we address that
first like b-roll almost doesn't matter
you can
and we have some on ours but it's not a
it's not a big deal like why are people
coming to watch your video they're
coming to learn
you know if I mean Andrew specifically
if Andrew who's doing Fitness videos or
recipe videos if you're going to be
showing off uh b-roll of the the food
or your biceps or you know whatever the
thing is cool but if it's b-roll of
somebody else like just some guy working
out in the gym then it's probably not
going to have a big impact and for the
most part it takes a lot of time to do
unless you're hiring an editor which you
could
but I'm here for education so what are
people here to watch they're here to
watch education just like when you're
going to watch a movie you're going to
go watch it for different reasons you're
going to watch it for a laugh you're
going to watch it for uh the special
effects like there are some movies that
you don't really care that much about
the plot or the drama because these
special effects are just so epic and
you're going for that's why you're going
you have to go watch it on the IMAX to
see the crazy special effects so inside
thought leadership
why are people coming they're coming for
the education they're coming for the
learning right uh so that's my quick
thoughts on B1 we can dive in deeper if
you want to maybe be real of yourself
doing something but for me it's always
cost benefit you know if that has a tiny
tiny like if it's a one percent
Improvement versus you spending more
time on the education or you making an
extra long-form video it's it's not even
close like go make the video
um I was talking to somebody who's a
movie makers and she spends you know a
couple out in her in her videos she
spends a couple hours
um planning and filming the videos and
then four hours editing the videos
it's like it's just not a good use of
time unless you unless you love editing
and you want to learn how to be an
editor
spending four hours editing a video is
just not a good use of time
what's better is to train yourself to be
a better speaker
and that first minute really really
matters most of you are probably good
once you're in the video at holding
attention
so if you're doing an interview you know
if Lydia's doing an interview with
somebody or Angie's going through his
workout routine
or sharing something on your iPad or
whatever like once you're into the
content you're probably pretty good at
doing it it's the first minute that
really really matters and we default to
thinking about like b-roll and such
um in thought leadership it has almost
no impact
uh Dana says what about a splashy intro
video as long as it contributes so the
intro really matters
think about somebody's experience so
they're trying to learn how to write a
book right in Dan's case I want to I
want to learn how to write a book I want
to write my book in a Flash I've got a
message in me I want to get it out there
the scroll mindset is definitely there
at the beginning because I'm trying to
justify why should I spend time on this
video instead of somebody else's video
and I'm making a judgment call in the
first 30 seconds as to do I want to keep
watching this video or not
we've tested so many different things
and we still test and it's probably one
of the most frustrating things that I go
over with my team
um especially Ivan who's been with me
for so many years is like okay but we've
tried that before we've tried that
there's like there's not stuff that just
struggling to find new things to try and
whether it's our own ideas or you know
we're modeling a Mr Beast video or
something else
um
we've tried theatrical intros with crazy
music and motivation we've tried showing
words on the screen and flashing it in
we've tried like massive Super Cuts so
like boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom and the thing that still has the
biggest impact that we cannot beat is
just going right in
with a powerful opinion
in education
because I am watching your video why I'm
not watching your video for
uh entertainment I mean maybe you guys
are really funny I'm not
you're not coming and watching me for my
jokes
[Laughter]
learn you're coming to learn you're
coming to get to to get better so if
somebody's in that education mindset you
have to lead with with teaching me
something that I don't believe
so
what do you believe that I don't believe
and you could add some visuals and think
of anybody here you know Andrew's
probably the most visual person
right because if he's talking about how
to get killer biceps I want to if I'm
coming on the video say here's how to
get killer biceps and I'm not showing
off the killer biceps it's like who's
this guy who's to tell me about a
workout routine where everybody else
here I think is more just about like
what's in your mind
right if Dan's gonna teach me about how
to write a book I can't I can't make a
judgment call like what's the set gonna
be maybe there's a ton of books behind
him it doesn't really matter though like
I'm trying to get the sense of what's in
his brain for all of you like how how do
I know if Phil's a good lawyer or not is
there a lawyer of the Year award that he
can hang on his what you know like I
don't know I can't make a judgment call
until I hear you speak for most of you
so then the most important thing to hook
attention is to hear you speak
so what are you going to share with me
that's going to make me stop the scroll
so if I want to if I want to write a
book I'm going through videos I see
Dan's okay I'm giving people like 10
seconds 15 seconds 4 seconds 30 seconds
I'm scrolling through videos before I
decide to go and watch that 20 minute
video and so you've got to capture my
attention in that first
30 seconds to minute
and if you can and keep them then
they're much more likely to stick for
the whole video and then having b-roll
and stuff in the middle of that video
has little to no impact
because it's an education
Evan yeah hey Pablo
um sorry guys I'm in in the God but if
one time you mentioned that um one of
the things that it can be good is when
we use two cameras and you show one of
your videos
you can this is like incremental
improvements
so if you have a second camera or a
higher quality camera it's incremental
improvements
um but I would always default to making
more videos than production quality of
videos quality of thought really really
matters
quality of thought is the most important
thing because you're a thought leader
because the thought leadership kind of
video so quality of thought really
matters production quality is not what
they're coming to your channel for
so if you're already at Maxi pass in
terms of making it if you're making
daily videos already then we can start
worrying about
production quality
otherwise like I'm I'm here I'm I'm
selling my place where I bought a new
home I'm selling my place
so it's being staged right now Lydia
says I like the colors but this is not
my usual kind of vibe and environment
um but whatever I can make videos from
here
it's not going to make a big difference
you know it would not impact my
retention
um as long as it doesn't impact how I
show up because if I show up and I'm
insecure and I feel like oh my gosh why
am I this is not my usual microphone you
know it's not my anything that you know
does it matter for you guys you know no
I was like that's it I'm dropping out of
analytics I haven't changed his
background he's not on this fancy
microphone
I'm out screw this guy right no because
you're not here because of my background
or the microphone I use you're here
because hopefully I've got something
that I can teach you from all the stuff
that I've I've learned and tested so
that's all like minor minor minor
improvements if I'm learning if you're
going to teaching Pablo how to negotiate
then all I care is that I'm going to
learn how to negotiate
and having a second camera again go
Prove It Go prove it wrong
you know it's not that you can't do it
they're just usual it's usually minimal
improvements for most thought leaders
and the amount of effort goes through
the roof
the amount of effort to then especially
if you're doing it yourself
right if you had a team or somebody
coming in and filming you cool then that
let them do their thing if it's you now
having to set up two cameras and then go
find b-roll and then edit that all
together then that usually that that
um
that equation doesn't work out
and the better solution is spend all
that time you're researching cameras and
setting it up and adding b-roll spend
that time to make a third video or a
second video or fourth video
or spend the time being a better speaker
training yourself to not need editing
so that the first minute is punching
because if you spend for my movement
Maker's friend who spent four hours
editing the video if she spent four
hours practicing the speech or
practicing what she was gonna say so
that she doesn't need editing
that's a that's a better skill that will
serve her forever
because you guys will have to whether
whether YouTube is still around in 30
years or not the skill set of
communicating to a camera is never going
to go away
when we're all Holograms and beaming
into uh Michael's living room
having a session it's still talking a
bunch of cameras right and so that's a
skill set that's worth learning instead
of if you're interested and you're
passionate about it cool yes go for it
but if if it's just a strategic move
like hey I think this is really going to
help my channel then I would default to
making you better instead of making the
production quality better quality of
thought definitely definitely definitely
um
yeah you can go prove it wrong like go
go try a second camera and see and show
that the retention is better
um but every time I've seen production
quality go up
you hope like this is it now I'm big
time you know now I'm ready to go and
then like oh it's the same
we talked about going longer and this is
a relatively new thing
uh if you go back two years on YouTube
even a year on YouTube it wasn't as big
a deal as it is now inside of thought
leadership and it's super weird because
almost everybody else is going shorter
YouTube Shorts YouTube stories Instagram
reels Tick Tock everybody's going
shorter
in thought leadership it's like don't
even worry about shorts I haven't seen
anybody win with shorts we have two
shorts channels I haven't proven that
that that it is worth your time or
investment I'm telling everybody to go
long go long long longer longer
10 minute minimum but go half an hour go
an hour go three hours if you're good
like if you know what you're talking
about if you can give a master class it
has a much better chance of helping you
build the channel and build a business
that you want as opposed to the really
short videos uh so just to refresh your
back to the top
the hashtag YouTube Longs says true uh
Eddie posted this video this was his
challenge that we had after the last
month post a three-hour video and he did
and because he posted to the group and
guys share your stuff in a group share
your win share what you need help with
because you might get featured on a
future for analytics session you never
know
let's look at this video so I uh I was
on I as soon as Eddie posted this and
like ooh let's see how it's doing let's
see how we're doing Eddie I want this
video to win is Evan Karma go right or
not
doesn't work because Eddie's also kind
of On The Fringe of thought leadership
right it's not just a talking head or
coaching videos it's on the motivation
side
so
views are down
right this is this is uh days so this
video is nine days old and Views are
down and this is where people freak out
you know they look at their one their
two days like oh my God this video sucks
like it's half of what my usual The Gray
Line represents the usual this is what
an average ready would do and the blue
line represents this specific video
uh so it's down but look hey it's
catching up it's catching up to our
average already this is actually pretty
fast
I would I would say even within a month
suggested to get suggested to grow is
fast
I would be expecting typically in like
the 30 to 90 days where it starts to
take off and then over 90 days for sure
but if you're getting it to start to
catch up inside of the first two weeks
you're doing a really good job so
overall views are down okay
watch time oh that's some nice watch
time look at that watch time that is a
delicious looking curve right that's
this video and this is his average so
he's already double his average watch
time in the first nine days
all right so amazing amazing start
let's look at why
so these two curves represent suggested
is the blue line and browse is the green
line and I looked at it yesterday and
browse was still at the top just barely
but today
gotta check back in this morning to get
the most recent day that suggested is at
the top so you see browse is going it's
good it's decent and it's still climbing
but it's this is what happens with
browse like it takes off at the
beginning and then it just slowly keeps
going hopefully and maybe you'll get a
pop every now and then because you hit
the home page but suggested this curve
can keep going forever
so already inside of nine days suggests
it has passed his brows
which is great
you look at the average view duration
and these numbers may be a little hard
to see but uh I'll just read it out loud
suggested 33 minutes
browse 16 minutes
because how long people are watching
so in browse you're only watching for 16
minutes which is still great that's
still a good number
but they're watching for 33 minutes when
they come from suggested it's double
and that's why it's starting to take off
and you'll see that people on the home
page will have a much shorter attention
span this this should go this should be
repeated if you look at your own
everybody here you look at your own
channel stats look at the average view
duration browse versus suggested
it would shock me if brows was higher
suggested is is always number one
so that's where we're gonna go because
YouTube cares about watch time so we're
giving them lots and lots and lots of
watch time here right so even though the
views are half
like the views are 1500 versus 3000 the
watch time is already more
we're getting more watch hours from
suggested with half the views
this is a great video
uh I took a screenshot yesterday last
night this is this one and I took a
screenshot again this morning this is
this one you can see it's already it's
picking up it's already doing better and
look at the number one traffic Source
last night suggested was 42 this morning
suggested it's 48 suggested is number
one this video has an amazing future
shelf life ahead of it
what's Drew saying uh oh you have more
data from Ben's Channel yeah I mean
getting data is not an issue there is
tons I have tons of data on this I want
to share
um not Ben so I want to share uh this
one because hey Heidi's in the group now
the other thing that Eddie was really
concerned about was well what if I go
and upset my community
what if I upset the people who are here
who are used to my four minute seven
minute 10 minute videos they don't they
don't want a three hour long video if
you look at the comments
I haven't seen a nasty Eddie this suck
stop posting long videos right you're
awesome brother keep up the great work
you surely are shining your light in the
darkness of others so freaking good
thank you thank you so much bro this
compilation is absolutely amazing thank
you buddy for inspiring right
so the comments the the data is showing
us that it works but the qualitative
data with the comments is also uh really
helping us
now just as a quick comparison the next
video he launched was two days later and
was four four minutes something
so three hours the one we just looked at
the next video was for almost five
minutes
I hate four or five minute videos inside
that leadership uh but let's look at a
quick comparison to see right so so far
this one has more views the shorter one
has more views
even though it came out two days later
the views are actually decent this is a
good video for him right the gray line
is average this is this reviews and he's
at the upper end of his average reviews
which is great
the watch time though is way below his
average
and that may or may not catch up
the difference is here
we look at his real time I pulled this I
don't know 30 minutes ago there's no
suggested on this page
browse notifications channels YouTube
search other features so if suggested
here it's less than five percent this is
a big problem so this these kinds of
videos put you on the the rat wheel is
that a thing hamster wheel the hamster
wheel put you on a hamster wheel
thinking Rat Race and hamster wheel
combined becomes rat wheel this video
puts you on the rat wheel where you
basically have to keep making video
video video video video video
just to get the short-term views but
there's no long-term sustainability on
most of these because you can't rely on
browse notifications is going to go away
because notifications uh you know it's
only at the very very beginning of a
video and with no suggested it's going
to go down and that says I'm on the rat
wheel
kind of new term uh and also without you
know diving deep and sharing all revenue
numbers for Eddie this video is getting
less than half of the CPM so even though
it has more views right now short term
out of the gate it looks better this
video is is going to be a lot harder for
him to get views get subscribers and is
making less than half of the CPM on the
video compared to that three hour one
that he just did cool let me just share
a couple examples and we'll from from my
top 10 channel so
this is one we did here
now this is a newer thing right this is
an old video this is 500 days old
so the views this is an hour long video
where normally I'd be making you know 15
to 20 minute videos so it's hour 20
massively underperformed on the views
but now it's picking up on The View so
now it's in the average of our views
the watch time was you know average but
now you know it's popping a lot harder
this one same thing 400 Days old like
this is a relatively new thing where
YouTube is really showcasing promoting
longer videos
I wouldn't have recommended the strategy
back here
400 days ago
but past six months heck yeah
so views massively underperformed and
then boom took off
watch hours you can't even see the
average line it's you know it's tiny
there this one took off
and if you just look at the traffic
sources you can see why right the blue
line is suggested
um the green line is browsed so as you
get more suggested it'll be recommended
and browse more too you'll see these
often browse can Trail suggested but
it's 69 coming from suggested
so going along makes that huge huge huge
difference if you want to see this full
video as well as trained live with me
twice a month to blow up your brand join
the brand Linux training program there's
a link to join right there next to me
continue to believe I'll see you there